ces guides marc bonjour malgré les très
fortes chaleurs ils sont quelques
dizaines rassemblés en soutien aux
libanais et oui tout à fait suffisant de
dire braver le mercure la très forte
chaleur pour se réunir et 6e place du
trocadéro à un simplement donc en
soutien au peuple libanais l'heure est
au recueillement comme vous pouvez l
imaginer certains ont d'ailleurs affiché
sur des pancartes
les noms des victimes de cette explosion
qui a ravagé toute une partie de la
ville de beyrouth l'ambiance ici est
sereine contrairement aux manifestations
qui ont secoué la capitale libanaise
hier mais le message est le même ici en
france comme au liban tous demandent la
démission du gouvernement qu'ils
estimaient être responsable de ce drame
et goûter seule phrase c'est que dieu
protège le liban des politiciens
libanais et qu'on leur apporte notre
soutien et on est de tout coeur avec eux
et demander la démission du gouvernement
libanais bien sûr évidemment bas ils
devaient protéger le liban c'est ce
qu'elles n'ont pas pu faire pour moi oui
bien sûr qu'on est politiquement là on
est aujourd'hui on soutient
un an les manifestants devaient route
hier on a tous vu les images atroces
commises par la police et l'état
aujourd'hui on a vu qu'il ya quelques
quelques ministres et ont commencé à se
a démissionné des députés aussi on
demande que tous les autres fassent
pareil et je pense pas qu'on va
s'arrêter là il faut qu'on les poursuive
tous parce que ce qu'ils ont fait
l'argent qu'ils ont volé les crimes
qu'ils ont connu ça ça peut pas passer
comme ça inaperçu je sens comme contenu
contre les libanais ce sentiment qu'il
faut faire quelque chose
on n'en peut plus ça fait plusieurs mois
que les gens ne peuvent plus manger ne
peuvent plus manger j'ai pris en un seul
mois deux mois ils ont été multipliés
par sept départs 8 c'est inadmissible et
en même temps on leur explose en plein
figure donc de cours effectivement et
voilée au maximum là où ils peuvent
aller mais en tout cas la situation
optique et actuel quoi qu'il arrive ce
n'est pas acceptable alors ça n'est pas
la première fois que les sympathisants
les banes réuni 6,6 passes depuis le
trocadéro
on a le souvenir du mouvement de
protestation de l'hiver dernier les
libanais manifestaient déjà contre la
corruption et pour la démission de leur
gouvernement alors cela a été dit la
ministre de l'information a annoncé
qu'elle quittait ses fonctions plusieurs
députés ont également annoncé qu'ils
démissionnaient mais face à la crise
économique face à l'inflation à la
montée des prix face aux coupures de
courant et face maintenant à ce désastre
il faudra bien plus que quelques excuses
et quelques démissions pour apaiser la
colère des libanais